how are you oh
exhilarated this is fantastic what are
you talking about wow wow i mean
first of all i i just have to i've
i've seen the movie i laughed it's
incredible i cried three times
it's incredibly interesting and how do
you feel standing here on this carpet
knowing that a legacy you built is
continuing on i planted the seed and uh
and then others watered the branches and
trimmed the leaves and got the branches
and the roots to grow and now uh what we
have here is something that
multi-generations enjoy we need all
three of you get in here
hey here we are
can you believe it all these years later
and this movie this franchise is better
than ever
well i haven't seen it yet so i hope
you're right but that's people are all
walking out crying so i don't know if
it's good news or bad we'll see i truly
cried three times i really i really did
um it's so funny it's so moving and you
guys it just knocks it out of the park
her and say that to the camera you
should what are you telling me that for
yeah but yeah that's great to hear
an amazing cast a great director and uh
and uh everybody
was doing uh you know their best to uh
to make it the right time and it is the
right time for it so before it wasn't
now it is how much is harold as he
should be on you guys's minds tonight
and what are you thinking about when you
remember him well he would always be on
time so he would have already made us
look bad he was very punctual and he'd
be just looking at us staring he was
punctual and prepared
and uh punctual and prepared and we're
not either we're neither of those things
we're raw
unfinished talent we're unfinished
diamonds we're very rough we disciplined
us
that's kind of what people love about
you i mean how many people on the planet
actually have your cell phone number
how many i don't know i don't do the
counting
anymore how proud are you guys of this
new young crew and what did you kind of
want to instill in them on set as they
take on the legacy
well i i don't know anything i could
instill i mean they they love the
franchise when they got into it they're
amazing they
i mean really really talented so there's
i mean i learned from them so it's just
yeah they didn't call it a franchise
which i resented you know they call it a
movie or a film or something and they
just thought it was a job but it's a
franchise
but they were good and we i didn't hate
any of them that's pretty good right did
uh did you guys do a lot of improv on
set or was it all the script
uh
well uh when mr murray's involved you
know you let him go
turn it on let him go let him go these
two guys
yeah these two guys you just hang on
some fun sure
and uh most importantly you know
something really serious
the sexiest man alive is in this movie
and i just wanted to know what you all
think of paul ryan congratulations
no no it's not me
well deserved you know he missed it
barely missed it this year but this is
next year this is the sexiest man alive
yeah
could we i was 103rd on that list
well i didn't make the list so there you
go people already want a sequel could we
see you all in another ghostbusters
movie well uh let's see how this one
does and maybe there'll be a interest
film i don't know if i could go on
without the sexiest man alive i'm not
sure i could do it again it's just being
on set putting the packs on again how
emotional was that what did that feel
like
like yesterday to me
i felt like i was called back to service
you know
well i saw danny in his jumpsuit and
bill and i i started crying so
apparently it was very important to me
well i really never expected to have
still another paranormal problem
[Music]